[Applause]
elon musk plowed his internet billions
into saving the planet one car at a time
cargo dragon takes flight then into
leaving the planet altogether say what
you like about him he's a man who puts
his money where his mouth is the very
definition of this deal because for much
of his career musk's mouth has been on
twitter
from the ground camera landing legs
deploying his timeline has celebrated
the success of his spacex launch
business attacked rivals and shared
harmless and sometimes harmful memes
he more than anyone knows twitter's
power he nearly collapsed his own car
company in an ill-judged tweet in 2018.
most analysts think this deal is an
affair of the heart not a cool business
head return on this investment is going
to be difficult freedom of speech is one
thing spending 44 billion on on it's
another and now it's about can he change
the platform subscription model you know
ultimately what are the changes in the
store because for musk he basically
traded some tesla shares about 10
percent of his stake for twitter shares
and i'd say that basically trading like
caviar you know for a slice of pizza
musk says he wants to restore freedom of
speech to twitter he's been critical of
bands imposed on people like donald
trump following the u.s capitol riots a
case study of the thin line between free
speech and violence but is it a line
that could be tried by someone whose own
behavior on twitter has landed him in
court
mr musk has made clear that he takes
free speech absolutist line if by that
he means
twitter will scrap its existing
moderation
measures to deal with violence and abuse
that
um would actually harm freedom of
expression and particularly for people
um
women and people of color and non-binary
persons
for now it's anyone's guess how much
twitter's new owner will change the
platform elon musk didn't become the
world's richest man by making too many
mistakes
but his success has been in solving
engineering problems not society's
problems in the political and moral
minefield of social media
tom clark sky news